hey you guys flickers of fear time once
again and we are continuing with our
folk horror february
now this movie here is one that's been
on my to watch list pretty much forever
i think that when i talked about uh
mario baba's classic black sunday which
i think was back around halloween
of 2021 i think i might have mentioned
this movie because
the movie black sunday is very very very
loosely
based on the same
short story slash novella
as this movie is based on although
seeing both of them i don't know if
you'd necessarily know that because
other than it being about a witch and
you know coming back to life and stuff
there's really not
a lot similar so this movie is called
v v i y
uh and it came out in 1967
based on a story by nikolai google
and this was actually as far as i am
aware
the first
uh soviet era horror film uh to be
distributed in the ussr because
obviously uh you know the soviet regime
wasn't too big on horror movies and they
kind of had to approve everything that
was going into a movie uh so this was
kind of the first uh one that got away
with being a horror movie and i guess it
kind of got away with that because it
was based on you know the work of a
respected author
and also it's not so much i don't say
it's like not so much like a
straightforward horror film but it's
more like
a folk or a fairy tale
so i guess it can kind of like get away
with it you know what i'm saying because
you can say oh it's you know it's just a
fairy tale now i will say the vibe of
this i know some of you guys out there
that are watching this are misties like
i am mystery science theater did a whole
bunch of
russian slash scandinavian type of
fantasy movies i'm talking about like
magic voyage of sinbad uh jack frost the
day the earth froze uh the sword and the
dragon
this is kind of in that same kind of
vein like tonally it's not as wacky or
not as over the top it's a fairly
grounded witch story so it's like more
of like a folk tale
than
some of the kind of more like way over
the top stuff
but
if you've seen those movies on mystery
science theater then you'll have an idea
of
what kind of like special effects you
can expect what kind of tone you can
expect from this movie
so this movie um
it's on shutter at the moment it's been
on shutter for like a really long time
and i kept meaning to watch it because
i'm like
it's uh it keeps coming up i don't know
if you guys if you don't have shutter
they have uh you know they have all the
movies that you can just look at in
alphabetical order or whatever but then
they also have them in collections and v
is always in their you know horror
essentials and i think it was the only
movie that was in horror essentials that
i had not yet seen and then when i when
i saw them talking about it on the folk
horror documentary i was like oh yeah i
really need to get around to watching
that because i feel like it was kind of
a gap in my horror movie knowledge uh so
especially because i'd already seen
black sunday
and i'd already heard about this movie
so i definitely you know wanted to get
around to watching it so i finally did
so it is on shutter it's also on 2b for
free uh if you want to watch it on there
at least as of february 2022. i believe
it's also on amazon prime although i
don't know if it's free or if you have
to pay for it you know what i mean so uh
so there are some places that you can
watch it
so
what we have in this story
so at the very beginning and now i will
say too
that it's a pretty short movie it's only
77 minutes
a lot of it probably like the first two
acts are kind of like
i'm not gonna say that it's almost like
comedic but there are like a lot of
goofy kind of moments now i will say i'm
not kind of i'm not sure
severin i think put out a really nice
remastered blu-ray of this
i'm not sure if it has the original
russian language
uh soundtrack like you know the the
talking and uh with english subtitles
because the version that's on shutter is
english dubbed now i don't usually like
that but you know what are you gonna do
it's so i'm assuming the one on tubia is
also english dubbed i kind of wish that
they had gotten the russian language one
because
as i said other than giallo films i give
them a pass but
every other movie i really really prefer
to watch and it's you know in its
original language i really don't like
it's just too distracting for me like
watching actors and knowing that that's
not their real voices and that did kind
of like take me out of it
for this as well so i'm not really sure
if some of the goofiness
uh was came from the dubbing which is
actually good as dubbing goes uh it's
not it's not terrible it's not over the
top but i you know it's it's just hard
for me to say that maybe it's some of
the dubbing that caused although
some of this stuff was absolutely meant
to be goofy so let's say like that but
yeah so but honestly like the first
i'm gonna even say maybe the first hour
of this movie is kind of like it's not
all goofy but it does have like a lot of
goofy moments in it and it doesn't
really go full-on horror until like the
last 10 minutes or so but that last 10
minutes is a doozy i will say uh so yeah
so what we have at the beginning there
is this seminary so there's all of these
dudes that are training to be monks
now
at the beginning
i guess they're going on break or
they're going on vacation or so i don't
know how mug school works so i don't
know so they're like whoo spring break i
don't know but they do kind of act like
that like the the guy that's the head of
the of the monk school is like now you
last time like you
you did this and that and you did this
bad thing and you stole all this [ __ ]
it's like let's not get up to these
shenanigans this time and like you all
behave yourselves and blah blah blah and
like all the monks are like yeah right
okay like that's gonna like that's gonna
happen but yeah so they they kind of go
off like frat
type of thing uh so they all kind of go
their own little ways for for mug spring
break
now there are three uh guys that are go
and travel together and they kind of get
lost the main guy
that we're following is a guy named coma
brutus who's the main character
now
as they kind of get lost um you know
after a spot of uh stealing some
chickens and some light sexual assault
uh
of some laundry women uh you know so
they kind of get lost and it's getting
to be dark so they see this farmhouse
like out and they're like hey why don't
we go up to that farmhouse and you know
we can stay there and they'll give us
some food and stuff and it's like it's
really funny to me i see this a lot in
these kind of like uh you know folktale
type of things like fairy tales it's
just kind of like so
you just like little little student
monks you're just like wandering around
the countryside and you just like go up
to a random ass person's house and be
like hey feed me and put me up for the
night and they like have to do it i'm
like that's some entitled [ __ ] right
there but and they're kind of dicks
about it too i gotta say
these three guys go up to this farmhouse
and
this uh very old woman uh who's actually
played by a male actor which happened a
lot in these kind of like
it was always kind of like witch
characters they always seem to be played
by men
uh but yeah so it was the case in this
uh thing as well
so this old woman comes out and she's
like well you can't stay here because i
have my house is full of people i don't
have any room
and the guys like start whining it's
like oh come on you know we're we're
from god and everything and like you
have to give us something to eat and
she's like okay [ __ ] fine um she's
like you can stay here but
all of you have to stay like in a
different spot like one of you can stay
in the loft and one of you can stay out
here and then she seems to take a shine
in particular to coma it might be his
bowl haircut i'm not real sure um
he's actually he has a good looking face
but it's kind of hard to pull off that
hair i i can't really think of anybody
that could pull off that hair but you
know what i mean
uh so yeah so he goes to sleep in the
barn
and then later on uh the old woman comes
out and straight up starts to uh
essentially seduce him
and the guy's like uh no thank you
i mean this is a very very old woman
actually a very very old man
playing a very very old woman
and uh he's just like yeah no not for
all the tea in china or something like
something to that effect
and uh so
so the old woman decides well you know
if you're gonna be that way
then i'm gonna do this [ __ ] right here
and she basically kind of puts a
sort of spell on him
climbs up on his shoulders
and starts riding him like a horse like
he starts to fly and like she's uh
sitting on his shoulders and they're
like flying through the air and stuff
and he's just like what the [ __ ] is
going on you know what i mean like his
feet are moving and he's like flying
through the air and stuff it's green
screen effect and you can tell that it's
green screen but it actually looks
pretty good because like i said this is
a fantasy movie so
it's kind of like you know you know like
when you see those sim bad movies like
with ray harryhausen and stuff like that
it's like yes it looks fake
but because this whole
uh the whole kind of like theme of this
movie or the whole you know it's a
fantasy and so it's all artificial so
you kind of like buy into it you know
what i mean so it you know the special
effects you can say you know it's 1967.
um you know you could say they recruit
or whatever but they still look cool
though it like gives the movie like a
real charm
so uh finally so he's riding around with
this old woman on his back hag ridden
that's what they call that
and uh he finally twigs onto the fact
he's like oh this is a witch and i'm
like yeah no [ __ ] it took up like quite
a while to figure that [ __ ] out uh so
yeah so this witch flies him around and
then finally they land and he starts
beating the [ __ ] out of the witch like
with a stick or whatever
and uh then the voice was like stop stop
stop you're killing me and then he looks
down
and suddenly it is no longer like a
creepy old woman but is now a very very
beautiful young woman and it appears
that he has killed her or at least
beaten her to within an inch of her life
so at this point he's just kind of like
oh [ __ ] i better get the [ __ ] out of
here so he takes off
now he goes back to the seminary uh and
he's just kind of like okay we'll [ __ ]
that vacation i'm just gonna i'm just
gonna hole up here for the for the rest
of the time
uh but then kind of like the head of the
seminary comes to him and says hey um
this rich guy in this next village or
whatever uh his young daughter is dying
and she asked for you specifically to
come to this village to you know say
prayers over her like while she's dying
and he's like what the [ __ ] why would
she ask for me i'm just like a monk
student i'm just i'm a trainee you know
what i mean it's like how would she know
who i am and all this other stuff he's
like i don't really want to go
and then uh you know the the head of the
monk school is just kind of like oh
you're absolutely going or you're gonna
get lashed so
you know he's like you seem to think
this is like a democracy and you can
just like do what the [ __ ] you want well
that's just not how monk school works so
he's like you have to go the guys are
already here with the cart get your ass
in there
so he goes to this town
now
it will surprise no one when he goes
into the church in this village
uh the rich guy comes and talks to him
and says you know my daughter is dying
um she actually dies before they get
there uh you know so they thought that
she was still gonna be alive by the time
they got there by the time they got
there because they stopped for vodka
just like so many times russia y'all um
you know what i mean so by the time they
got there she was already dead
uh so
the the rich guy the girl's father is
basically like well i don't know why
like she asked for you specifically and
i want you to for the next three nights
i'm gonna lock you in this church with
her body and you have to say all these
prayers over her so her soul goes to
heaven or whatever the hell
now
the dad is kind of like suspicious like
well
do you know my daughter and obviously
like coma is like looking at the girl
going oh [ __ ] that's the girl that's the
witch that i beat to death
and he's like no bro i totally don't
know she i don't know why she would ask
for me
of all people maybe i just have like a
really cool reputation or whatever
although he's very oh i will say one
thing about coma is that he is very open
about how not
uh holy he is you know what i mean he's
just kind of like even when he's reading
out of the bible he's like why shouldn't
we be allowed to smoke why should we be
allowed to get drunk all the time why
shouldn't we be allowed to like you know
grab women's asses and stuff like that
so you know at least he's not like
pretending he's not like being
hypocritical i guess but yeah so he
tells the dad i don't know her
i never met her i don't know why she
would ask for me specifically to come
here but if you want me to do it i'll do
it and the dad is basically like you
know you're gonna i'm gonna give you all
this money if you do it so he's like
okay fine but again he he does lie to
him and he says i don't know why your
daughter asked for me even though he
absolutely does because he's essentially
the one that killed her right uh so
because he's the one that beat her
and so uh but he basically says to the
dad he's like may god strike me dead if
i'm lying right now god doesn't strike
him dead so the dad like buys it
so the rest of the movie from then on is
his kind of like three night ordeal so
they lock coma into this church and it's
really cool looking like with all the
creepy like i guess it's russian
orthodox like art or whatever those
creepy [ __ ]
jesus is and stuff i love that [ __ ] so
uh so it's all over the walls it's like
this big wooden thing with like zillions
of candles everywhere her body is in the
middle in this big black coffin
and so he goes in there at first and
he's kind of like a little weirded out
because as i said he recognizes her and
he knows that he's the one that's
responsible for her being dead and he
kind of feels bad about it uh so
he's maybe suspicious that some [ __ ]
because he does know she's a witch
nobody else in the village i think some
of the other village people the village
people i think some of the other dudes i
didn't be the same village people i
think some of the other dudes in the
village like suspect that she's a witch
cause when they're all sitting around
drinking which they do a lot of in this
movie okay they kind of tell him a story
about that's very similar like what
happened to him like this woman that was
riding around on another dude's
shoulders like it was like he was a
horse so i think that maybe some of the
villagers kind of suspected she was a
witch but maybe they were afraid to say
anything because like the rich guy owns
the village and he would have him killed
or whatever i don't really know
so he's locked into the church uh for
the first night and he has he lights all
the candles up and he uh
makes like a circle around he has like a
podium that has like his bible on it and
he makes like a chalk circle around
there like protect him
uh so
it doesn't take too long before
uh unsurprisingly the witch wakes up
and starts to try to get him
but because he has a circle around
himself like she can't get in now at
first it seems like she can't see like
she's sort of like feeling around
and then she does like some marcel marso
[ __ ] like she's trying to get into his
uh you know magical circle and stuff and
she can't get in there and he's like
flipping out as you would because
obviously he thought this woman was dead
um he knows she's a witch and he's like
oh [ __ ] i killed her i'm in big [ __ ]
trouble now
but for the first night he is able to
like stave her off uh you know because
he has the circle on
so they let him out in the morning and
you know he's drinking again and the
other guys are like so uh what happened
in there last night
again the way they like react makes me
think they probably knew like some [ __ ]
went down but he's like plays it real
cool he's like nothing you know i just
heard some noises and stuff that's
that's all nothing nothing bad happened
but then when you know when the second
day like the second night starts to
approach and he's you know it's getting
to be time where he has to go back in
there he starts kind of like freaking
out again and like drinking a lot and
what not and like all the villagers are
like are you like scared goings no no
i'm a cossack i'm not we're not scared
of anything and uh you know but
obviously he's like pissing his pants in
terror
so again he gets locked in for the
second night and again the witch wakes
up and like flies around and like tries
to get him and [ __ ] um you know this bit
of the movie a little bit
you know it's not going in a direction
that you don't expect um you know he's
locked in there three nights and that's
pretty common like in fairy tale type
stories i guess you know it's always
kind of like in threes
so second night it just seems like each
night it's getting like worse and worse
so uh so at that point it's it's getting
worse like the witch is really like
flying all over the [ __ ] place and it
looks really cool actually she's kind of
like i really liked the one shot where
uh she's in the coffin and there's like
a lid on it and like the lid just like
pops off you know what i mean and she
just like comes out and then she's like
flying around like trying like trying to
get him and she looks really cool like
her outfit and everything
and so uh so he survives the second
night but after that that was like so
scary he's like man [ __ ] this [ __ ] i'm
just like out of here and he tries to
run away but they actually do find him
or bring him back and the rich guy is
like look you have to see this [ __ ]
through to the end you have to do all
three nights if you do it i'll give you
like a thousand pieces of gold if you
don't do it then i'll give you like a
thousand lashes which will probably kill
you now that i'm thinking about it
so uh so he's like really
kind of thinking about not doing it he's
like no i better do it that's a lot of
money and again has to fortify himself
with lots and lots and lots of vodka
before he goes in for the third and
final night now the third night
is when
all hell breaks loose literally and this
is actually like pretty much the coolest
part of the movie as i said up to then
it's kind of like sort of predictable
and it has like some kind of goofy stuff
you know everybody's like constantly
drunk um he's like every dude and this
is like just a drunken idiot pretty much
and uh it's just like falling all over
and singing and you know and and
whatever and dancing and stuff like that
it's just like very silly
but this last part like this third night
when he gets locked in there uh that's
when
the that's when the [ __ ] like pops off
you know what i mean because not only
now
is the witch in there but then like all
these other demons like start coming out
of the [ __ ] walls and just all kind
of crazy [ __ ] happens this is like
absolutely the best part i really really
liked all of the
design like all of these like
guy they're all like painted
with this
uh so it's a lot of little people and
then it's just kind of like you know
regular-sized people and they're all
kind of like painted this sort of like
bluish green type of color and they're
all [ __ ] up looking and they're all
like climbing out of like holes in the
walls and like running down the walls
and they did like all these really cool
um like visual effects some of them have
wings like bat wings and they could like
fly around and [ __ ]
and uh you know there's there's these
one parts where they're like these big
huge like clawed hands like there's a
whole bunch of them like coming
surrounding him and [ __ ]
and then at the end like the witch like
to get him
she finally summons v who is i guess
head demon head monster whatever who
it's i mean it's obviously like really
really fake looking but
i don't know i really kind of liked this
monster design like he comes in and he's
this big lumbering
lumpy
monster
and my favorite thing about him was that
his eyelids he has big [ __ ] eyelids
like that and he tells the other demons
he's like you guys i can't see him like
i can't see coma he's like can you guys
flip up my eyelids he doesn't say it
like that but he's like you guys flip up
my island so i could see him and they
like literally they have to manually
like put his eyelids there are like
hinges is like i'm like oh my god that's
so cool and like his eyes are like all
big and glittery and [ __ ]
and uh so yeah so uh so coma essentially
gets like surrounded by all these demons
and they're all just like beating the
crap out of him and [ __ ] like that and
uh that's gotta say spoiler alert that's
pretty much the end of coma you're not
entirely sure
whether he dies or not because they kind
of like
they leave it you know all the demons
are there they're just like you know
wailing on them and stuff and the envy
is there the monster and the witch and
everything and they're all like [ __ ]
with him and then you know the [ __ ]
crows outside like you know it's dawn
which obviously they have to scatter
they have to disperse so they do that
and then they just leave coma lying
there and then they kind of like fade to
black and then like the last scene is
just his two buddies like his two
compatriots that uh you know got lost
with him earlier like at the beginning
of the movie and they're sitting out
front of the church like supposed to be
working like supposed to be painting but
of course they're drinking uh and you
know slacking off
and uh they you know one of them says oh
let's have a drink to coma you know it's
sad that he died and do you think the
witch had anything to do with it blah
blah but then the other guy says i don't
really think he's dead maybe he could
walk up to us right now so they leave it
kind of ambiguous i haven't actually
read the uh story this is based on so
i'm not sure if that's
accurate to how the story ends or not if
the ending is left ambiguous as to
whether como is actually dead or not but
they leave it ambiguous in the movie
you're led to believe that he probably
is dead but they leave the possibility
open that maybe he's still around
somewhere although as i said it seems
more like a straight ahead
revenge story i mean it seemed like he
pissed off the witch by not not
succumbing to her advances
you know when she was in her uh old
crone form
uh so
she decided well i'm gonna ride you
around like a horse and then i'm gonna
punish you
by you know turning young and hot and
then dying and haunting your ass and
making you
be in this [ __ ] church with all the
demons and everything so i'm assuming it
was just like a revenge story you know
what i mean but you know you can read it
any way you want to uh actually so this
movie
it's weird because it's only 77 minutes
but as i said like the beginning part
it's it's shot really well and the
acting seems to be really really good as
well um like i said hard to tell because
of the dubbing i really wish that i had
seen it uh russian language if i watch
it again uh i'll definitely try to seek
out that version because i'm sure that's
much better
uh but like i said the english dublin
dubbing is not bad i mean i've seen like
a lot worse than that but it is still a
little bit distracting uh so keep in
mind that it is a fairy tale and it does
have a lot of comedic or kind of like
goofy
sort of elements leading up to it
but that said once he gets locked into
the church there's still kind of some
goofy [ __ ] because he's scared and he's
trying to talk himself out of being
scared
and that's kind of like funny like in a
scooby-doo sort of way but
as the you know as the nights progress
and it gets worse and worse it actually
slicks some of the imagery particularly
in the last 10 minutes when all the
demons come and you know v the monster
comes and everything are actually really
really cool like there's some skeletons
walking around and [ __ ] like that it's
just so it's really really cool like the
look of it um but don't go into it
thinking that's going to be the scariest
movie ever or
you know something like that it is
it is very much like a fantasy a fairy
tale
and
it's kind of like i'm glad i saw it i
don't
i didn't love it but i really did like
the imagery toward the end you know what
i mean it really did have like some
like some really cool
creepy kind of look to it at the end and
i really like that i actually liked the
whole witch situation too but you know
the the set design was really really
nice like the inside of the church i was
really into that um but yeah it's it's
like a fun
movie and i really
think it's it's interesting to watch
like as a historical
artifact because it was the first horror
movie to come out of the soviet union
but if you like
a lot of those kind of you know russo
finnish fantasy movies especially like
the ones they did on mystery science
theater then you should probably check
this out because this is kind of very
similar
vibe to that and you probably really dig
it but yeah this is definitely one that
pretty much everybody's i know you
probably should see it at some point i
think that they did um a modern
retelling of this in 2014
i'm not sure what country it was done in
but i haven't seen that so i don't know
if it's any good
but as i said it's it's nothing like i
know it's supposedly based on the same
story as black sunday but because black
sunday was so loosely based on this
story um really the two movies hardly
have anything
in common with each other other than
being about a witch and you know there
being like scenes of like a witch in a
tomb you know what i mean uh that's
pretty much the only thing that i can
think of that's similar but you know
it's just a fun colorful
witch movie that
as i said it's interesting as a
historical artifact because
of its uh production history and things
like that and it's a pretty decent uh
folk horror fairy tale uh type of movie
so
if you've seen v from 1967 uh let me
know what you thought about it in the
comments uh if you'd like to watch it as
i said it's on shutter i believe you can
also watch it on 2b for free and you can
watch it on amazon prime although i
don't know if it's free with amazon
prime subscription or if you have to pay
extra but let me know if you've seen it
if you did what you thought about it and
that will do it for this flickers of
fear as we continue our folk horror
february and i will see you guys on the
next one
bye